C'è un momento esatto in cui ti rendi
conto che il sangue a volte è veleno. Ti
sei mai chiesto perché, nonostante tutti
i tuoi sforzi sovrumani per tenere unita
la famiglia, [musica] certe relazioni
sembrano destinate a sgretolarsi tra le
tue mani?
Forse hai pregato per avere pace, per
trovare un compromesso impossibile, per
farti accettare da chi avrebbe dovuto
amarti incondizionatamente.
Eppure, più ci provavi più la distanza
tra voi si faceva incolmabile,
lasciandoti esausto e svuotato.
Oggi voglio dirti una cosa che potrebbe
sconvolgere tutto quello che ti hanno
insegnato fin da bambino.
E se quell'allontanamento doloroso non
fosse un tuo fallimento, ma una risposta
divina?
E se Dio o l'intelligenza superiore
dell'universo stesse letteralmente
tagliando i rami secchi per impedire che
l'infezione raggiunga le tue radici più
profonde? In questo video esploreremo
una verità scomoda e potente. Ti
mostrerò come la saggezza [musica]
biblica unita alle scoperte della
psicologia moderna rivela che perdere
una famiglia tossica spesso non è una
punizione, ma il più grande atto di
protezione che tu possa mai ricevere
nella tua vita. Immagina la tua
esistenza come un giardino prezioso che
ti è stato affidato in custodia
esclusiva. Per anni hai annaffiato
piante che, invece di fiorire e darti
ombra hanno assorbito tutta l'acqua per
poi rilasciare spine e tossine nel
terreno. La cultura in cui viviamo,
specialmente quella italiana
profondamente radicata nell'idea del
Natale tutti insieme a prescindere, ti
fa credere che la famiglia sia
un'istituzione intocabile, [musica] un
altare sacro su cui devi sacrificare il
tuo benessere mentale pur di mantenere
le apparenze. Ma la scienza ci dice una
cosa molto diversa e i numeri fanno
riflettere. Il sociologo Carl Pilemer
della Cornell University ha condotto uno
studio monumentale durato 10 anni,
scoprendo che ben il 27% delle persone
adulte ha tagliato definitivamente i
ponti con almeno un membro della propria
famiglia d'origine.
Non stiamo parlando di capricci
adolescenziali o liti [musica]
passeggere.
Stiamo parlando di adulti che hanno
dovuto amputare un arto per salvare il
resto del corpo dalla cancrena. Quando
un familiare [musica] ti manipola, ti
sminuisce costantemente o usa il senso
di colpa come un guinzaglio invisibile,
il tuo sistema nervoso vive in uno stato
di allarme perenne, producendo cortisolo
come se fosse in guerra. Il distacco
emotivo, in questi casi estremi,
[musica] non è un atto di egoismo
crudele, è un protocollo di
sopravvivenza necessario per non
impazzire. E qui entra in gioco un
concetto sconvolgente, una verità
millenaria che raramente viene predicata
dai pulpiti tradizionali.
Hai mai letto con attenzione il Vangelo
di Luca al capitolo 14?
Gesù usa parole che sembrano pietre
scagliate contro il buonismo.
Se uno viene a me e non odia suo padre,
sua madre, la moglie, i figli, i
fratelli, le sorelle e persino la sua
propria vita, non può essere mio
discepolo. Fermati un attimo e respira.
Il Dio dell'amore assoluto che parla di
odio sembra un paradosso inaccettabile.
Gli studiosi del testo biblico ci
spiegano che nell'idioma aramaico antico
questo termine non indica il disprezzo
malevolo o la cattiveria, ma stabilisce
una precisa scala di priorità vitale.
significa amare di [musica] meno, o
meglio, significa che nessun legame
terreno, per quanto biologicamente
stretto, deve avere il potere di
allontanarti dalla tua integrità, dalla
tua luce interiore e dal percorso di
evoluzione che sei chiamato a compiere.
Se un genitore o un fratello ti trascina
nell'oscurità del suo narcisismo,
l'insegnamento più profondo e radicale è
che devi avere il coraggio di lasciare
andare la corda prima di precipitare nel
burrone insieme a loro. Pensa alla
storia di Giuseppe e i suoi fratelli nel
libro della Genesi.
È forse il primo grande trattato
psicologico della storia umana sulle
dinamiche familiari disfunzionali.
I suoi stessi fratelli, accecati da
un'invidia feroce, lo gettano in una
cisterna vuota e lo vendono come schiavo
a dei mercanti di passaggio. [musica] È
il tradimento definitivo, il dolore più
puro, perpetrato proprio da chi
condivide il tuo stesso tetto e il tuo
stesso sangue. Eppure, se guardi la
storia da un'angolazione superiore, quel
tradimento atroce è esattamente il
meccanismo che permette a Giuseppe di
arrivare in Egitto, crescere attraverso
le difficoltà, [musica] diventare
governatore e infine salvare un'intera
nazione dalla carestia.
Se i suoi fratelli lo avessero amato in
modo normale, lui sarebbe rimasto per
sempre a pascolare greggi in Canaan,
ignorando totalmente il suo vero,
immenso potenziale. A volte Dio permette
che chi ti sta vicino ti volti le
[musica] spalle in modo crudele, non
perché ti odia o vuole punirti, ma
perché l'ambiente in cui ti trovi è
diventato troppo piccolo, troppo stretto
per quello che devi diventare.
L'abbandono non è la tua tomba, diventa
la tua catapulta verso un destino più
grande. A te è mai successo di sentirti
divorare dai sensi di colpa per aver
messo dei confini netti con un [musica]
parente che ti faceva del male
sistematicamente?
Scrivimelo qui sotto nei commenti perché
so esattamente quanto pesa quel macigno
sul petto e parlarne insieme ci aiuta a
capire che non siamo soli in questa
trincea silenziosa. Molti di noi
rimangono intrappolati per [musica]
decenni in dinamiche velenose perché
confondono il perdono cristiano con
l'accesso illimitato [musica]
alla propria vulnerabilità.
Nel libro dei Proverbi c'è un monito
chiarissimo e affilato come una lama.
Chi va con i saggi diventa saggio, ma il
compagno degli insensati diventa
cattivo. Nota bene, non c'è un asterisco
a fondo pagina che dice: "Tranne se gli
insensati hanno il tuo stesso cognome".
L'energia delle persone che frequenti è
contagiosa come un virus ad alta
trasmissibilità.
Se chi dovrebbe incoraggiarti passa il
tempo a demolire la tua autostima goccia
dopo goccia, a ricordarti i tuoi
fallimenti passati come fossero trofei o
a competere segretamente con te in ogni
occasione,
ti sta lentamente avvelenando l'anima.
Perdonare significa liberare te stesso
dal rancore corrosivo.
Non significa affatto invitare [musica]
chi ti ha appena pugnalato a sedersi di
nuovo al tuo tavolo con un coltello
affilato in mano. Forse in questo
preciso momento stai affrontando il
vuoto gelido lasciato da un distacco
recente. I pranzi della domenica sono
diventati improvvisamente più silenziosi
e c'è una sedia vuota nella stanza che
fa un rumore assordante nella tua testa.
Voglio che tu guardi quel vuoto non come
una perdita irreparabile, ma come uno
spazio finalmente ripulito dalle
macerie. Gli esperti di dinamiche
familiari tossiche ci insegnano che il
sintomo principale di una famiglia
disfunzionale [musica] è l'obbligo
assoluto del silenzio omertoso. Chi dice
la verità, chi espone il problema, chi
smette di fingere che vada tutto bene,
diventa immediatamente il capro
espiatorio da abbattere.
Se ti hanno isolato o se sei dovuto
scappare lontano per non impazzire,
significa che sei tu l'anello forte che
ha rotto l'incantesimo della menzogna
generazionale.
Sei il portatore di una verità che il
sistema malato non poteva tollerare
senza collassare. L'isolamento
temporaneo che stai vivendo è il prezzo
alto ma necessario che paghi per riavere
indietro la tua lucidità mentale e la
tua dignità. [musica]
Dio o l'universo o la saggezza superiore
in cui credi, usa spessissimo il disagio
insopportabile per spostarti con forza
da luoghi in cui non dovresti più stare
nemmeno un minuto.
È esattamente come quando tieni la mano
appoggiata su una piastra rovente. Il
dolore lancinante non è il tuo nemico.
È il segnale d'allarme vitale che ti
costringe a ritirare la mano prima di
bruciarti completamente fino all'osso.
Se stai vivendo il rifiuto, la freddezza
o l'ostilità aperta della tua famiglia
d'origine, ti prego, non cercare di
forzare una porta che è stata chiusa a
chiave dall'altra parte. Smetti di
bussare dove non vogliono farti entrare.
Usa questa nuova immensa libertà, per
quanto all'inizio possa sembrarti
dolorosa e spaventosa, per costruire la
tua famiglia di elezione,
quella formata da persone che ti
scelgono consapevolmente per chi sei
oggi, per la luce che emani [musica] e
non per il ruolo sottomesso che dovevi
interpretare nella recita familiare di
ieri. Ricorda sempre e portalo con te
come uno scudo. Le tue radici non sono
solo quelle biologiche che ti hanno
assegnato alla nascita. Le tue radici
più profonde, quelle che ti terranno in
piedi durante le tempeste della vita,
sono quelle che pianti tu stesso nel
terreno fertile del rispetto reciproco,
della lealtà e dell'amore autentico. Se
queste parole ti hanno dato una
prospettiva nuova su una ferita che ti
porti dentro da troppo tempo, se hanno
acceso una scintilla di consapevolezza,
iscriviti a dose mentale.
Qui affrontiamo ogni giorno le verità
più scomode e affascinanti della
psicologia e della saggezza antica per
darti gli strumenti pratici necessari a
costruire una mente d'acciaio e una vita
finalmente libera dalle catene
invisibili.
Ti aspetto nel prossimo